you guys get the New York Times is
absolute trash you remember they wrote I
was on the freaking cover of the New
York Times a couple years ago on a
Sunday me Jordan Peterson Thomas sole
Ben Shapiro Milton Friedman about how
we're leading people to the alt-right
like the whole place is just absolute
it's just horrific trash
um but they're having their own problems
because uh not only are they just a
awful propaganda network but their
employees are on strike right now and I
wanted to show you this it's like a
minute video from Fox where they started
interviewing some of the New York Times
employees who are very upset at the New
York Times and you'd think that a place
a New York Times place a good
Progressive organization you'd think
they'd be treating everybody great and
things would be going just just cheeky
over there but apparently that's not how
it's working out what are you guys on
strike about we've been at the
bargaining table for 20 months now the
company is consistently coming into the
bargaining table with proposals that are
insulting and unacceptable the New York
Times is making record profits and the
people who make the news need to share
in them it's a variety of issues but the
big things are we haven't had a raise in
over two years what are they not giving
you they're not giving a basic floor
wages of sixty five thousand dollars
I'll be honest I don't know the details
that that specifically we have been
working through the entire pandemic
without any salary increases at a time
of record inflation is this about coming
back to the office
um it's also about coming back to the
office of course we also want to make
sure that we are protecting people you
know we're still living through a
pandemic remote work is part of the
negotiation we find it ridiculous that
the company is maintaining this position
that it have the unilateral right to
call us back in five days a week I
thought the New York Times respected
Union so what happened there you'll have
to ask them that's an excellent question
I I would love an answer to that as well
excellent question we'd love to hear
what the management has to say about
that yeah it's a very good question we
thought the New York Times respected
unions too what happens to the New York
Times when you guys are on strike we'll
find out we have said we're not going to
write stories we have photo people we
have electricians other people in the
building who are not working today they
have to figure it out on their own I am
refusing to write I'm refusing to
respond to edits I imagine they're
having quite a hard time putting uh the
product the publication together the New
York Times can't run without the people
who run the New York Times
and management needs to know that if you
guys are all on strike who's going to
write the fake news
well we don't actually think that we
write fake news what an extraordinary
collection of whiny losers like how else
can you describe it these people they're
so shocked that that the New York Times
is hypocritical that the same paper that
pushes all the stories about unions and
how great unions are it doesn't want to
do it when it comes to its own people
and you can't believe it the New York
Times dares wants them to come back into
the office and these little children
pretending we're still in a in covid and
pandemic everything you all deserve
everything you can get